[Musique]
trente ans d'autorité bafouée 30 ans de
république kittin et 30 ans de repères
oublier 30 ans d'éducation sacrifier 30
ans d'école dévasté 30 ans d'instruction
saccagé 30 ans de marseillaise chuchoter
30 en justice négliger 30 ans de police
attaquée 30 ans de culture pulvérisé
parmi les formules qui sont le plus
revenu sur twitter on retiendra que la
seule gif autorisé en démocratie c'est
la gifle électorale l'agression physique
est totalement injustifiable écrit un
internaute on lit aussi beaucoup de
messages du type quoi qu'on pense de lui
on ne siffle pas un président de la
république ce à quoi de nombreux
internautes répondent qu'on le gif le
person to 30 ans d'histoire revisité 30
ans de promesses envolée 30 ans de
déconstruction obligé 30 ans discours
bâillonner 30 ans de gouvernement après
trente ans de territoires abandonnés 30
ans d' excuses avant ses 30 ans de
couleuvres avalées 30 ans de salades 30
ans de l'acheter trente ans de simagrées
30 ans pour rien trente ans et cette
gifle comme une sentence
non mais schiffli quelqu'un le prix
jeune la république mais même ici puis
quelques les données de ce pays de
complètement tordus qui répercutent
répercuter pardon leur mal être
alors que pour sa centrale est très bas
il faut sortir le production est allé
chercher à aller chercher son magistral
à la une du canard avec ce titre gislais
à tain l'hermitage un maquereau soupire
c'est tour de france on est déjà matelas
qui vous laisse apprécier les enough la
gifle a eu lieu à tain l'hermitage et
par conséquent des milliers
d'internautes ont pensé être les
premiers à faire le jeu de mots de la
tarte tatin un jeu de mots renversant me
disais louis d'autres appellent à mettre
fin au cumul des mandats ce n'est pas
emmanuel macron qu'on a attaqué hier
c'est la france
on a agi flée il est temps de payer les
factures
celle ci a 30 ans je crois que tu n'as
plus de la commission parce que tu me
fatigues
non je te le dis tout ça ça te dit non
c'est non mais passé avec david guion
contradictoires écoute je ne sais pas je
te dis non je sors pas je te dis je suis
pas moi sans rien de plus en plus de
jeunes se revendiquent sorcier
pratiquants et s'échangent des astuces
pour jeter des sorts ou faire des
rituels espérons que je sais pas que
marine le pen est un tout dans son verre
dans qui n'ont pas qui la rendent malade
mais qui la rende qui lui ouvre les yeux
en se disant finalement peut-être que
j'ai une chance de gagner une élection
et que pour la gagne est complètement je
redevienne une grande démocrate que vous
êtes toujours comme cul et chemise amène
alors on dirait minutes
ces voix là j'étais passé mais cette
façon de parler tu suces non mais c'est
et ctu c'est une remarque est très 2
obligeant très sexiste d'autant plus que
tu t'installes hétéro je crois quoi ton
premier rapport c'est avec des poules et
des lapins
c'est ça on veut pas savoir ça ne nous
regarde pas non évidemment sorti de son
contexte ça peut prêter à confusion
rachida dati était l'invitée de la de
l'émission animaux stars sur la chaîne
animaux tv pour évoquer son chien un
entretien vraiment passionnant mais il
voit passer de passer à la télé ils
aboient et la boîte qui se met sur la tv
il commença à envoyer
mais non c'est pas vrai seul c'est la
vie parfum est ce que les vaches devront
un jour elle aussi porter un masque
c'est l'idée de kharg il le géant
américain de l'agriculture ce masque ne
serait pas utile pour les protégés de
l'aco vide mais pour protéger la planète
et oui c'est très sérieux en effet des
éructations des bovins seraient
responsables de 5% des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mondiales à cause du
méthane qu'elles relâchent alors le
masque vous voyez sur cette photo
permettrait de capter ce méthane et de
le transformer en eau et en gaz
carbonique beaucoup moins polluant
fléchit légèrement les jambes et les
bras vers le sauveur
voilà chantier contre david hasselhoff
égérie de la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc vide en allemagne dans ce
spot diffusé en ligne par le ministère
de la santé l'acteur américain de 68 ans
rappelle ses grands succès elle se pose
[Musique]
alerte à malibu k2000 et sa chanson pour
la liberté interprété à berlin quelques
mois après la chute du mur la liberté
aujourd'hui dit il
oui c'est d'être vaccinés c'est très
difficile une carrière il ya des hauts
et des bas on en a connu on est bien
placé pour le dire mais
[Musique]
le temps j'ai passé un truc festive
prochaines vacances à temps plein ce
soir il y aura quand même un grand
dilemme un chef parce que y'a top chef
et il ya la réouverture des récents qui
sera le grand gagnant
non mais j'ai envie de dire allez au
restaurant à c'est une priorité puis
vous regardez ray top chef sur six
plaies
vous me faites peur mais je suis
tremblante sommes donc là nous entrés
dans la chambre
[Musique]
o la chambre à moi je pense que ça sert
à rien de faire un lit parce qu'entre
cause des dents avant le décès moi c'est
rien de se laver parce que le sort était
sale qu'on peut passer des semaines sa
soeur irene se maquille et puis tout le
temps ce débat qui donc en fait autant
laisser reposer la prod invite à raison
mais ca
mais vu comme ça t'as vu comme ça ces
mecs
oh lola mais qu'est ce que c'est chaque
pièce
si vous les activités professionnelles
est ce que c'est que tous ces produits
d'entretien jeu suivant série est
produite entre les deux produits data
les réseaux
moi j'ai détesté toyer à chaque fois
qu'il faut nettoyer genre chez moi au
genre partout je fais exprès d'avoir
envie d'aller aux toilettes
sauf que là elle veut tu ne dois tout la
maison je peux pas rester deux heures
aux toilettes il profitera cutter mais
passer à la télé c'est quoi ces
gamineries c'est quand même un truc de
singly peut-être je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus là dessus de ça je vais lui
poser la question pourquoi vous êtes
passé récent les bouffer leur montage
avec les jambes on ajouté
oui mais j'ai l'impression a toujours
jeudi montrent aussi un beau les gens
aujourd'hui moi on n'est rien du tout
dans ce sens mais qui sommes-nous en
fait j'arrête de penser ça me fait mal à
la tête